well bridging the home ownership gap
between african americans and other
races
it's an issue still very prevalent in
our country and right here in the valley
but some of the brightest minds are
coming together this weekend to address
it
madison kimbrough joins us now live with
more on what to expect madison
yeah denise there's an event this
weekend focusing on the basics of home
ownership and the pattern of it along
with generational wealth building
for blacks we're about 35 of all blacks
own a home
whereas for whites it's 62 percent so
there's the gap
this saturday the make homes possible
coalition is hosting a live
online webinar speaking on this exact
topic it's called master class on
building black wealth with home
ownership
this master class that we're hosting on
saturday we're going to teach
the process to home ownership we're also
going to teach how to get access to
up to twenty five thousand dollars in
down payment assistance even if you
aren't ready to buy a home the master
class will provide knowledge and
resources for you to use in the future
homeownership is the heart of the
american dream right
where we live where we get to raise our
kids it affects you know
our health our safety it affects our
communities at its core and so that's
why it's so important creates a
vicious cycle when generations of
families are kept out of home ownership
the urban chamber of commerce nevada
housing division and the city of las
vegas are all in partnership with this
event
set to launch at 10 a.m this saturday
you can register at
makehomespossible.org
and as of now the master class has over
a thousand people registered but there
are still open slots
of course we'll have all that
information up on our website reporting
live madison kimbrough 8 news now